India generates more garbage...
...than every country in the world besides China.
The government has taken steps to address all this waste,...
...including a ban on single-use plastics.
But across the country, people are tackling the issue on their own.
From making tiles out of smog to filling teddy bears with old cigarette butts,...
...this is how India deals with worldwide waste.
These sneakers are made with garbage.
The company that makes them says each pair contains 10 plastic bags and 12 bottles.
Ten tons of food goes unsold every day at this market,...
...but instead of going to a landfill, it's turned into electricity...
...that will power street lights, buildings,...
...and a kitchen that preps meals for 800 people.
This is called biogas.
It's plentiful, it's low-tech,...
...and experts say it burns cleaner than any fossil fuel.